[Music]
joining me this week is an author a
television pundit host of a nationally
syndicated radio show and now most
importantly a returning guest in that
very chair
Larry our welcome back to the Rubin
report thanks for having me I appreciate
it well I am looking forward to this
because I mentioned at the top of the
show that I don't know that any guests
that I've ever had on challenged me
directly as much as you did and actually
managed to change some of my feelings
that got to feel pretty good for you
well I had a lot of good feedback from
the interview and people complimented me
but I said the the condiments should go
to you because you were asking questions
and unlike a lot of interviewers you
really cared about the answer you
listened then you responded and so I
think it will maybe interview so great
so for you to sit down with a liberal
and I think last time we literally
didn't know each other I think maybe we
had met for 10 seconds before you sat
right there you sit down a liberal and I
think that you were ready to go so when
I said talking about systemic racism but
you were ready to tell them you did and
I my guy said to me after we don't even
do in the show for a few months you know
do you want to edit that part out
because there's a part where you really
kind of catch me in like a moment where
I don't know and we'll link to it right
down below I want people to see this I
think it's important how hard is it for
you to sit down with liberals generally
speaking and have an honest conversation
depends on the liberal if it's an
open-minded liberal who really cares
about what you have to say it's pretty
easy if it isn't if it's somebody who
who's already decided what they decided
and believe that liberals that
conservatives are mean people rotten
people cold people anti science people
they were going to be in for a bumpy
night right
okay so let's I want to just recap a
couple of things we talked about last
time for guys I haven't seen and then
we'll get to all the new stuff so real
quick just tell me a little bit about
your political evolution how do you end
up here as a conservative well it wasn't
so much an evolution as it was kind of
like a series of things that happened to
me people like met books that I've read
and that all together you add it up and
I ended up being a conservative my
father was always a Republican my mom a
Democrat and so at the kitchen table
they would fight all the time about
politics and when I was younger I sided
with my mom
I think partially because it was just my
mom and when I got older I began to
fight with my father much to my mother's
consternation so going back that let's
say 50 ish years roughly what it what
are the types of things that your dad
was fighting for as a Republican at that
well I remember vividly during during a
Watergate my dad was defending Richard
Nixon which I thought was indefensible I
thought what Richard Nixon was accused
of doing with Sabrina suborning perjury
and getting other people to lie was was
deeply wrong my dad thought it was
trivial my dad felt that Richard Nixon
had not done anything to enrich himself
that national security was not
jeopardized nobody died why would you
impeach a president over the fact that
he was trying to cover up a break-in to
the Watergate that was my dad's position
my mom's position of course was that
Richard Nixon was a crook and a liar
fast forward the polls show that most
Americans now believe that Richard Nixon
should not have resigned over what he
did and feel that what Hillary did was
far worse and she did not have to resign
yeah what does that say about just sort
of how where we've come and where we
were that we're so obsessed with scandal
right now and what we know right now
Trump in an office bird as we're taping
it's like five days in London and it's
like there is just going to be massive
scandal after massive scandal Obama said
just completed that he's very proud that
his administration got through without a
major scandal now that depends on where
you're desperate I suspect you disagree
with that but in terms of like a
personal scandal or some real feeling of
something or that kind of thing but but
maybe you don't see it that I do not see
it that way but your question was what
does it say about us where are we gone
yeah it says about us is that when it's
Republican in office somebody like
Richard Nixon that people did not like
there's one level of scrutiny and one
level of judgment one of us one of us
when if it's when it's a Democrat
somebody like Clinton or like Obama
there's a whole different thing for
Obama to say with a straight face and
I've not had a major scandal are you
kidding me Willis fast and furious what
was Hillary's a email server what was
denying the nonprofit applications of of
conservatives with the with the IRS what
you can have your doctor you can keep
your doctor and Obama reiterated that
line after it was obvious from the from
the rigs that you couldn't necessarily
keep
a doctor or you couldn't necessarily
keep your plann so why didn't he
basically say that the ends justify the
means that's sort of what you're saying
like I had to sell it and we kind of
knew I'm not defending that that
particular line but that was sort of a
occult I still think in a scandal
yeah for you to say that you're going to
bend the cost curve down people are
going to be no worse off they're going
to save money and you don't save the
money when you know full well that you
can't keep your doctor if you want to
keep your doctor and to say it anyway
that to me as far as I'm concerned is
the scandal pulling out all the troops
out of Iraq over the advice of his
entire national security team Hillary
wanted him to keep a stay behind force
his Secretary of Defense wanted to stay
behind force the CIA director wanted to
stay behind force the Joint Chiefs
wanted to stay behind force our US
ambassador to Iraq advised Obama against
pulling all the troops out he did it
anyway and the media gave him a pass for
that and Ray Odierno the retiring army
general of the Joint Chiefs said that
have the troops not been pulled out Isis
could have been dealt with that can be
is a massive scandal for which Obama got
a pass and still gets a pass so is that
one of the situations where we're damned
if we do and we damned if we don't
so that had he stayed at most people and
I'm guessing you and could you probably
didn't want us to be there forever
having left the way he did they were
having democratic elections right before
that I mean literally in the months
before we left they were having their
first free democratic elections and now
now it's an absolute disaster so is that
just one of those situations there was
no win in a way for him at the end
because either we're going to occupy
them forever or we're going to pull out
and then some bad stuff can happen which
is exactly what okay now now we're
talking about kind of the merits of the
Iraq war and and whether or not we
should have stayed or not stayed and
that's fine look I believe that as long
as the American public did not have the
will to stick it through because what
George W Bush said was we'll leave when
Iraq can stand up as long as the
American people did not have the will to
do that we shouldn't have gone but I'm
surprised I think George W Bush is
surprising Dick Cheney is surprised that
over the advice of all the people that I
just now mentioned Obama pull all the
troops out anyway he envisioned a stay
behind force to make sure that Iraq
would be stable I mean we stayed in in
Germany we stayed in Japan we're still
in South Korea
it takes a while for dinner we have
30,000 troops in Germany now or
something like that something like that
it takes a while for for democracy to
take root and for us to bail out the way
we did was was incredibly irresponsible
and I thought jeopardized national
security and again I am surprised that
Obama felt confident enough to walk into
the Oval Office and ignore the advice of
all these people so when you are going
to be basically that these these
scandals these issues that you brought
up basically he got a pass because the
media is sort of in on it with the
Democrats is that the basic idea
absolutely for him to say if he said
many times during press conferences I'm
most proud of the fact that I rescued
the US economy really the major things
that were done tarp and bailing out the
auto companies george w bush had set
that into motion his stimulus program
most economists don't believe it did
anything obamacare with a brand-new
entitlements dropped on the back of the
job creators and notice how he no longer
bragged about things like cash for
clunkers and cash for clunkers he does
even cash for clunkers whether it is
talk about that anymore because they
were boondoggle if they did not work the
coffe American people American taxpayers
money okay so I know that a certain
amount of people are going to hear what
you said there and go that doesn't make
any sense them than the other there's
going to be a very 50/50 split on
probably where we people where people
are app afford it so let's move to some
of the philosophical stuff which i think
is ok where we can get into the real
meat of it right so racism this is the
issue that more people contacted me
about when I was discussing you than
anything else is where you challenge me
the most on systemic racism so first off
what does any racism exist in America
not systemic racism we'll get to that
effect but what racism is real right we
live in a country has got 330 million
people roughly eight to ten percent of
them believe Elvis is still alive almost
half of them believe you sent us a
letter you'll get it obviously there's
racism there were individuals who don't
like other people because of their race
no question about it but are there
corporations they have a policy of not
hiring anybody or are there governmental
agencies and policies not hiring anybody
the answer is no if you can tell me the
company IBM Apple that has a policy of
not hiring black people tell me or brown
people tell me what that company is and
we can deal with it I
what people need when they talk about
institutional racism just were the 50s I
would know what you're talking about
when there was what there was a
segregation that was legal segregation
in the south where you couldn't marry
somebody outside your race in certain
states but that is no longer the case
right now the racism that people talk
about right now in my opinion is
individual stuff where some individual
doesn't like you or some individuals
don't like you but is it something that
if anything akin to what we experienced
in the 50s and 60s absolutely not and I
think it's insulting to people who have
fought hard and died in the 50s and 60s
to get us to this point to act like
things are just the same yeah when you
have people like Eric Holder saying as
he did when he was AG we now have
permission a sysm which he said was
every bit as bad as the old racism what
the hell are you talking about
I mean it's insulting to me so what do
you do to defeat that idea so again this
is you you mentioned that in our
conversation and really did you know you
got me I said well there's systemic
racism and you said well what companies
can I just ask you for an example yeah
you got me and so I do agree with you
there are racist people there are
certain amount of people that don't like
black people that don't like you they
don't like gays etc we live in a free
country you're allowed to not like
people it may be odious and unpleasant
but you're allowed to you can't harm
them but correct but what do you do to
stop the idea of what you're talking
about that things have changed for the
better and that there's a certain amount
of people that want that oppression that
want the oppression because it sort of
puts them above other people how do you
fight that you've been trying to fight
it I think prolong down tell the truth
that's how you finally tell the truth I
mean or go this movement called black
lives matter I think we talked about
that a little bit it it's as bogus and a
phony in movement as the notion that OJ
Simpson is innocent from having killed
two people it's a fraud most cops simply
want to do the job and come home most
cops frankly are more hesitant to pull
the trigger against a black suspect than
a white suspect there have been a couple
of studies that have shown that recently
one of them was a economist from Harvard
named Roland fryer and he is apparently
the youngest tenured professor in the
history of Harvard
and he's a tenured professor in the
Department of Economics and he did a
study to find out about police brutality
he assumed he would find the opposite
and he was shocked he said when he found
out that most police officers are more
reluctant to use deadly force on a black
suspect than a non black suspect and the
reason in my opinion is pretty obvious
if you shoot a black person and there's
any question whatsoever about it you're
going to be under the gun you're going
to be possibly prosecuted maybe lose
your pension maybe go to jail
cops are deathly afraid of being
perceived as engaging in racial
profiling it was a recent poll it just
came out and it turns out 75% of cops
say that they are more reluctant now to
engage with citizens than than before
before the black lives matter movement
yeah so what's the disconnect then when
you when you see these cities when you
see Atlanta and you see Chicago and you
see Ferguson and all of these places
that are usually under Democratic
control they usually have Democratic
mayor's right look the groupthink would
tell you wait a minute Democrats are
helping black people so where is the
disconnect coming from a lot of people
are not thinking critically based and
just not take take Baltimore Baltimore
with run by a black mayor she got 85% of
the vote what kind of politician gets
85% of the vote yeah exactly guys I
think it's elegant it's got a 35% yeah
and the top two officials running the
police department were black the command
staff majority black all city council
Democrat majority black the state
attorney the one who brought the charges
against the six officers is a black
female and yet and still they're still
talking about the systemic racism the
fact of the matter is a lot of black
suspects are engaging in bad conduct and
the police are doing their job and often
the bad conduct is against another black
victim yeah does this all come down to
education for you because at the end of
the day if you can teach people properly
about history and if you can teach them
properly about what the role of
government is and all the things that
that's really how you untie this stuff
from just the screeching people on both
sides
III think so and but but it's also all
about rationalist Left connecting the
dots is it really true that that a young
black man
it's more likely to be pulled over by a
cop than a young white man and if it is
true then another question is why and
you cannot have a meaningful discussion
about any of this without talking about
behavior I think maybe the last time we
were here we talked about a National
Institute of Justice study that's the
research arm of the DOJ they did a study
that came out in 2013 called traffic
stops and race and it turns out that
whether you're talking about driving
without a license or driving while drunk
or driving with a busted tail pipe or
driving without a seatbelt or driving
without a car seat in the back it turns
out black motorists were more likely to
commit those crimes than a white
motorist and the study said that the
differences in stopping have to do with
differences in offending if you can't
have a meaningful discussion unless you
have a meaningful discussion about
behavior right now I suspect that some
people on the Left would hear that may
say well black people have been
oppressed economically so they are more
likely to have a taillight out or some
other thing you would just say that's
nonsense you would just say that's
individual responsibility you got to
drive a car that's supposed to be the
one that's on it well that's right also
there's more poor white people in the
country than there are poor black people
but if black people that complain about
being dis fortunately pulled over
yeah it's half of all the homicides in
this country involve black victims
almost all of the black victims were
killed by other black people I don't
know what they have to do with cops
being racist it has to do with the
faculty disproportionately large
percentage of crime is committed by a
law a small percentage of people usually
males usually young black males often
against their peers and that is because
of the lack of fathers in the home I
didn't say it Obama said it the kid
raised without a father is five times
more likely to be poor
nine times more likely to drop out of
school and 20 times more likely to end
up in jail the number one problem facing
this country is not bad cops not
Obamacare it is the large number of
children raised without fathers that is
a product of the welfare state between
1890 and 1920 1930 believe it or not a
black kid was slightly more likely to be
born to mothers and fathers married to
each other than a white kid so what's
the connection there what's the 1920
connection to the welfare state starts
and why does that harm the black
anymore the welfare state really got
kicked off in the mid 60s 25% of black
kids were born outside of wedlock in
1960 yeah right now it's 73 percent and
what happened is literally Lyndon
Johnson launched a so-called war on
poverty and he sent workers literally
knocking on people's doors to apprise
women of their right to welfare provided
there was no man in the house and so
what we've done is change the culture
we've incentivized women to marry the
government we've allowed men to abandon
their financial and moral
responsibilities it is a neutron bomb
dropped on this country all because of
the war on poverty that was done by
Lyndon Johnson and the Democrats and
with with the tacit support by
Republicans as well and again if it was
a claim note we know that there's a that
there is a negative incentive because in
1996 when Bill Clinton signed the
Welfare Reform Act of 1996 welfare
declined by over 50% far steeper than
anybody predicted it turned out there
was a bunch of able-bodied people in
able-minded people sitting on couches
and when when the when the jig was up
they got off the couch you gotta think I
work yeah do you think the intentions
are good
so when Linda John Ambulance pushes this
when the Democrats and the Republicans
accountable were their intentions we're
going to help people get out of re or is
there really something more nefarious
going no the intentions were quite good
FDR talked about the corrosive effect of
government dependency when he launched
it the New Deal and Lyndon Johnson
talked about getting people off of
government dependency and making them
more self-sufficient by launching the
war on poverty those were their stated
goals and I believed them but human
nature is such that if you allow
somebody and easy out some people will
take anything out and that's what we've
done
with a lot of people so basically we've
said to a certain subset of people and
it I guess is a disproportionately
amount of black people we've said you
can get a certain amount of government
handouts and basically your argument is
that this is now just leaving people in
the status quo because if you can get
something subsidized housing whatever it
is writing stance and you don't have to
do anything you'll just take it that's
not a black characteristic that's a
characteristic of what L what any human
our human nature and there was a poll
taken in 1980
six by the other times they have poor
people and non poor people a bunch of
questions and one of them was do you
believe that that poor people have
additional children to get additional
money from welfare the majority of non
poor people said no they probably
thought it was insulting if not racist
64% of poor people said yes also they
were asked this question poor people
were do you believe that welfare is a
crutch cuase dependency or do you
believe it's a means to get you to stand
on your own two feet and go forward more
of them said it was a crutch that
created dependency than it was a means
to get you on your own two feet and go
forward these are poor people responding
to this poll yeah so basically guilt has
a lot to do with this the guilt sort of
white liberal guilt in a way has
actually subjected black people to a not
all black people courts but a certain
subset of poor black people to a set of
circumstances that they almost can't get
out of I think that's part of it but
also I think part of it is people that
are comfortable and wealthy and
well-educated look around to figure out
how they can perfect the world and they
forget that part of getting anywhere is
overcoming obstacles and and struggling
and if you make things real comfortable
for people some people are gonna take
the easy way out so I think it's a kind
of mindset the kind of mentality yeah
when did we get to that point we're
fighting for what's yours fighting that
no one should give you anything that the
government isn't supposed to give you
anything and no one should that it is
your life to live it is your it's your
job as a human to do what makes you
happy and take what you can
that doesn't mean destroying everything
around you but but finding what makes
you happy when did that get crossed up
is it all connected to this evening
that's a good question I think the
founding fathers intended for us to have
what people have characterized as rugged
individualism article 1 section 8 of the
Constitution set forth a handful of
things the federal government should do
they did not include Social Security
they did not include Medicare does not
include Medicaid they do not include
charity but we've gotten away from that
I think because if people become more
and more affluent they look around and
try to protect the world yeah would you
roll back all of those do you consider
yourself a libertarian I do you're
basically a libertarian yes so so you a
libertarian
well I'm a loyal order libertarian so
you think there should be driver's
licenses of course yeah so you're not
like well because it's an important
distinction to make because there are
plenty of libertarians that don't so
you're so what makes you not a classical
liberal man because that this has become
one of the themes I don't like I am I am
a classical liberal and the John Stuart
Mill sense of it yeah absolutely I am
somebody who believes in maximum
personal freedom but also you have to
believe in excellent personal
responsibility and that is to deal with
the consequences of your choices yeah
and a lot of people don't want to do
that they want to shell people from the
the vestiges of the world of life and
when you do that you also will create
some other kind of reaction that will be
worse my father used to say when you try
and get something for nothing you often
end up getting nothing for something
yeah so what sort of social safety net
should there be that or do you not think
that there should be and this may be the
difference between a small L libertarian
and a classical liberal I I think most
classical liberals feel the way I feel
and that is that the safety net should
be provided by other individuals not by
government but by churches nonprofits
one of the things that Alexis de
Tocqueville wrote about in democracy in
America where all of these with it were
called mutual aid societies that were
set up this is before Social Security
before Medicare before Medicaid and
believe it or not a black person living
in Chicago in the 1920's 1930's was more
likely to have health care insurance in
the white person because he joined these
mutual aid societies that provided that
[Music]
you
[Music]